The first answer is negative 12 plus 8i, and the second answer is 22 plus 14i.
If you figured either one of these out, great work. We start this first one by
distributing the 4i to 2 and to 3i. 4i times 2 equals 8i, and 4i times 3i
equals positive 12i squared. This is just kind of like x times x. We know x
times x is x squared, so i times i is i squared. Okay, here comes the important
part. We want to substitute i squared with the value of negative 1. So here's
an i squared, so I'll replace it with negative 1. This is the key step to
multiply complex numbers. You already know about distribution, and you already
know about combining like terms, but you might not have known about that
substitution. This is how we get a result of positive 12 plus 8i. For complex
numbers, we usually list the real part first followed by the imaginary part.
This is why I put the negative 12 here. We either have a plus bi, or we have a
minus bi. These are the two forms that we'll see. For our second problem, we
start by distributing this positive 3 to the 4 and to negative 2i. Next, we
want to distrubte the 5i to our second parentheses. We'll have 5i times
positive 4, and 5i time negative 2i. We can clean up our multiplication to get
12 minus 6i plus 20i minus 10i squared. We have like terms of i, so negative 6i
and 20i equals positive 14i. The other terms stay the same. Next, we have i
squared. So we need to replace that with negative 1. This means we'll have
negative 10 times negative 1, which would equal positive 10. Whenever we have
an i square term it essentially makes the number negative. Like here, we had
12i squared and we get negative 12. Whereas here, we have negative 10i squared
and we get positive 10. Now we're ready to combine our final like terms of 12
and 10 to get our final result. Now again, don't worry if you struggled with
this one. You'll have a chance at the next one.